the case that is that is now being made
again is that
everything in america that we don't like
is due to the systemic racism of the
united states and
is a data point in favor of the idea
that america is systemically racist the
latest case that's being used
on this basis of course is the derek
chalvin case
this is why you see dan jones making the
case that if there is no conviction
it is open season for cops dan jones
says that that if we don't convict derek
calvin
then cops will be able to get away with
murder in broad daylight
no that is not what that means that is
not what that means you see jonathan
capehart
saying the exact same thing jonathan k
part of the washington post here he is
making the case
that he is ready for not guilty because
america is racist not because of the
details of the case we don't need the
details of the case that's
that's irrelevant he's ready for not
guilty because of america's history
everything is just evidence of american
racism i
am already prepared for
a not guilty verdict and i and i
you know i hesitate to say that but just
given
given the history of this country in the
history of these situations
i have to ema intellectually
and emotionally prepare myself for that
okay meanwhile chelsea handler again
another member of the left she says we
shouldn't even have trials
in cases like this one right the
narrative is so strong
you don't even need a trial due process
goes away so chelsea handler genius that
she is
she tweeted out so pathetic that there
is a trial to prove that derek schalvin
killed george floyd when there is video
of him doing so
oh that makes sense we shouldn't have
trials anymore
no more due process we'll just go
straight to the conviction because after
all
who needs due process when you have the
narrative now here's the realities i've
mentioned about this case
this is a heavy lift for prosecution and
this is not an easy case for the
prosecution
and she double down on that by the way
she perhaps we skip trials when there is
audio and video footage of the murder
but there are several issues that still
have to be adjudicated here
okay so for example the prosecution has
to show beyond a reasonable doubt
not by preponderance of the evidence
beyond a reasonable doubt
that floyd's death was caused by derek
chavin's actions
but the autopsy report shows that floyd
was high on fentanyl and meth at the
time and had a serious heart problem
and shows that chalton's neck hold
didn't in fact cause damage to floyd's
trachea which means he didn't damage his
airway
which means that while shaving's neck
restraint could have contributed to
floyd's death by ratcheting up his blood
pressure for example
it's uncertain that it caused floyd's
death more than say the arrest in the
first place the excited delirium the
floor was pr that floyd was pretty
obviously in before he was even on the
ground
that's before you even get to the
charges right that's just the basic
causation issue in order to charge him
with manslaughter or murder you have to
show that his actions led to floyd's
death
okay and it can't just be but for
causation right but for shalvin
being there doing that he would have
lived it has to be that his actions
actually cause the death
there's a pretty strong medical case
that that may not in fact be the case
in a second i'm going to explain the
actual charges okay again
the narrative here is that america is
racist that anything that we don't like
is due to american racism and this is
just another example of that
okay but there are very specific
questions that are asked in court on
these sorts of issues
so let's talk about the charges for a
moment there are three charges that are
being brought against eric shelvin one
second degree murder two third degree
murder and three
second degree manslaughter second dream
second degree murder
is a is a fairly heavy lift it requires
that the prosecution prove beyond a
reasonable doubt
that chalvin unintentionally killed
floyd while intentionally committing a
felony
so the question is did he intentionally
commit a felony did he believe
that he was committing felony assault on
george floyd when he was
holding him in a minneapolis police
department approved neckhole by the way
for eight minutes and 46 seconds while a
crowd of ongoers
uh onlookers was yelling at him now
again it's not just
do you believe that that's true or not
the question is do you believe it beyond
a reasonable doubt
reasonable doubt is a very high standard
of proof
so a jury could easily find that this is
not beyond a reasonable doubt
felony assault requires intentional
infliction of bodily harm that chalvin
wanted to hurt floyd
not just use a suppression tactic that's
already been greenlit by the minneapolis
police department
is there evidence that he actively
wanted to hurt floyd there or is there
evidence that he was negligent
he'll get to negligence in a second
because that brings us to manslaughter
case
third degree murder depraved heart
murder that one
doesn't really seem to hold because
depraved heart murder the legal
definition
requires that you acted in a way quote
eminently dangerous to others
others plural so usually depraved
murderer is a drug dealer distributing
drugs
that are tainted in some way such that
they will kill people and you distribute
them to a number of people
and you know somebody's gonna die you
didn't have specific intent to kill one
direct person
but you knew that there was a good shot
that somebody was going to die you fire
a gun into a crowd you drop a brick off
a freeway overpass onto the cars below
right that sort of stuff is depraved
heart murder this has a specific alleged
victim
and that means that you are really not
looking at his depraved murder so third
degree really shouldn't even apply in
fact
a higher court at one point had thrown
actually the trial court
originally throughout the third degree
murder charge and then it was reinstated
by a higher court and finally their
second degree manslaughter and this is
the one
that is most likely that chaven is
convicted on but if he's convicted of
manslaughter and not of murder do you
think jonathan k part is going to
reevaluate
his belief in the racism of the american
system i don't by the way even if even
if chavin is convicted do you think
jonathan k part and van jones are going
to reevaluate
their beliefs about the racism of the
american system of course not
because it is a premise that must never
be challenged the racism of the american
system
because so long as there is disparate
outcome it must be the system
and here's the thing there will always
be disparate outcomes so long as people
make disparate actions and so that
second degree manslaughter charged in
the shaving case it requires the
prosecution prove
that chaven acted with gross negligence
but
gross negligence would have to show that
chaven should have known his behavior
might cause floyd's death okay and
that's that's
a hard case to prove did like why would
he why would he think
that that would cause floyd's death to
put him in a neck hold
that is a basic suppression hold again
approved by the minneapolis police
department
you have to prove that he intended to do
that that at the very least he was
negligent
in that he knew that what he was doing
could cause somebody's death well
barring barring floyd's underlying
conditions
that really shouldn't cause your death
right if you don't have a serious
cardiopulmonary issue to begin with
plus meth in your blood plus fentanyl in
your blood makes it real difficult so
here's the thing
sheldon could easily be convicted there
is certainly a case for chavin to be
convicted on second-degree manslaughter
lines
annie mccarthy has made that case over
at national review but if he is
acquitted
that's not because of the racism of the
american system that's because due
process of law requires a very strong
showing of evidence
and proof but all the media are going to
show is all the inflammatory stuff from
the trial
the media are going to pretend like any
defense of derek shalvin by his own
defense team
is somehow racist in and of itself all
they're going to show is is the
witnesses
to what was obviously
a tragedy at the very least speaking
emotionally about the issue so for
example
one of the witnesses yesterday called
the cops animals
on the stand which raised an objection
here's what that sounded like
when you were watching this interaction
between these three minneapolis
four minneapolis police officers and mr
floyd were you watching a cage match at
the time
well i only seen two of them the animals
so i was watching more of a humane
show okay objections
okay and uh he suggested that uh he was
watching a
humane bleep show humane bleep show
um and uh he said i was not watching a
sport okay
all this sort of testimony is
provocative but it really is not
probative providive means it doesn't
actually contribute
to whether there is guilt here or not
right it doesn't go to the underlying
fact pattern
but most of the testimony that's gonna
be shown on late night tv and throughout
the day on on your 24-hour news networks
is going to be the witnesses saying that
they stayed up nights for example that
was
one of the witnesses said yesterday it's
been nice
i stayed up apologizing
and and
apologizing to george floyd for not
doing more
and not
physically interacting and
not saving his life but it's like
it's not what i should have done it's
what he should have done
okay so you know obviously this sort of
stuff it would be heart-wrenching it
would be terrifying it would be terrible
but that doesn't go to the probe of
value here but what you're going to see
is the most evocative
emotional testimony you're not going to
see any of the underlying fact pattern
presented
on national tv because that might
actually undercut the narrative that
this is a straightforward case with an
easy solution
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content